moment le retour du burger quiz c'était
hier soir sur tmc grand retour d'alain
chabat
c'était il ya saison sur canal + 5 ça
avait été créée et sa carte tonéo
l'audience 1,9 million de
téléspectateurs pour le premier épisode
1,8 million de moyenne donc on a plain
d'image à vous montrer on voulait vous
parlait déjà d'un achat bas c'est lui
qui était présentateur emblématique du
jeu à l'époque on vous a préparé un
petit magnéto pour vous présenter ton
style et son humour regarde ce soir
c'est normal ça se bat déjà une
avalanche de tweets c'était mieux avant
quelle merde c'est tout pourri sale juif
marine revient
bonjour edouard chien bonjour je suis
formidable parce que quand bürgi parle
web bouger votre bouche alors les
téléspectateurs ont bien aimé les jeux
concours auquel il devait répondre ce
que vous aimez ou est ce que vous
n'aimez pas burger quiz des bottes petit
temps car tu es il devait répondre à
aller voir les questions étaient
vraiment absurde regarde 7000 euros
en répondant tout simplement une
question sms combien de doigts
suis-je en train de montrer un
2 2 37 tirs l'agneau est plutôt un
animal doux et gentil de un prédateur
assoiffés de sang y at il une vie après
la mort on chante comme questions plein
d'extrême d'agir a dit vous avez aimé
alors moi j'adore je vénère moi j'ai été
shootée aux pochade nuls au happening
des robins des bois et c'est tout ce que
j'aime dans l'humour ça s'est racheté un
côté sale gosse mais ça reste bon enfant
et j'ai trouvé que c'était très très
réussie
maxime j'aime beaucoup ce programme il
est dit leur est absurde du ray pour des
trentenaires comme moi ça me parle
beaucoup à l'époque j'avais 14 ans et ça
tombe bien que ça revienne
et en plus se croit qu'il ya 40 numéros
qui ont été commandés par tmc
alors gilles verdez pourquoi vous n'avez
pas alors j'ai détesté vous me
pardonnerez monsieur le ministre mais
les démissions mais c'est pas lui qui
produit la norme et non mais on n'est
pas ministre un an ce que je veux ce
crétin d'état pense que je vais dire
excuse un peu aussi c'est pas trop qui
vous a aidé à sa méthode mais c'est
normal c'est que ça c'est pas vrai que
ruines
et vous avez pour le producteur de vin
parce que je n'avais rien à voir avec
noah télé monsieur merci ce que je vais
m'acheter voulant que les quelques
utilisateurs un banc du quai de la moi
cette émission aurait pu n'être qu'une
merde mais c'était une merde infâme
hommes ce qui s'est passé la question
sur les juifs et les arabes
c'est un scandale et uniquement parce
que les médias diffusent le meilleur des
nuls on voit tout ses blagues l'agent ça
très bien passé ici pas sinon on va voir
l'extrait parce que c'est elle effectue
en effet rien il y en a beaucoup qui
vont nous parler de cet extrait voilà
c'est une question car qu'est économique
mais les gens ont bien aimé je vous le
dis regardez les candidats devaient
répondre à une série de questions avec
les réponses juifs arabes ou les deux
regardez c'est ça qui nous a choqués
isama salon ça a beaucoup fait réagir
hier ça regarde les deux catégories du
jour sont juifs ou arabes
bonne ambiance les arabes ou les deux
chiffres bonne réponse
le but de chaud je vous me dîtes si je
me trompe bien se faire les palais dans
le centre n'est pas d'aller dans le sens
de la réconciliation
pas forcément voilà le dernier
il faut les exterminer ça va un peu plus
d'écho des voix alors vous jure que ça
vous a choqué c'est vraiment énorme
c'est un sujet quelconque chaque pour
moi c'est insiste voilà on au passage ou
aidez moi j'ai été choqué on ne peut pas
jouer avec ça aujourd'hui ce que ce sont
des questions qui sont extrêmement
pernicieux je vous dis la vérité là vous
allez dans le sens c'est toi tout ce
qu'on déteste moi c'est à dire les
donneurs de leçons dessus et l'ascenseur
quand c'est drôle on peut rire de tout
justement et je vous le dis si alain
chabat et les personnes autour de la
table était vraiment raciste aurait pas
fermer ses bases on est là pour moi vous
dites une grosse message alors que pour
le retour de ce jeu il y avait là bas et
surtout qui est ce des canal est
justement ce genre de questions si à
passavant dans l'édition n a aucun
intérêt
c'est pour ça qu'on avait il ya qu'il ya
16 ans et c'est pour ça qu'on l'a vu que
ça a plu c'est à des failles
hier soir là où isabelle alors c'est
vrai qu'ils poussent volontairement leur
soeur un peu loin pour voir si ça passe
aussi ça casse maintenant c'est toujours
effectivement été la marque chabat en
résumé que luna bas et moi je trouve que
effectivement j'ai pas moi j'aimais
regarder puisque j'étais devant top chef
est charles ou à la fois mais nous
n'achetons pas tout faire non mais moi
j'aime j'aime bien
mais la personne je crois que c'est une
carte vous dire c'est vrai que si
c'était pas lui en revanche la jouer là
là je soulève le chômage s'il vous plaît
c'est vrai que les hommes en adn demain
avons fait ça chauffe et sa wii
franchement c'est là c'est pas trois
millions c'est sa c30 barre ajoute 10 et
30 bar tour du burger quiz
alors c'est un événement très attendu et
j'ai eu aujourd'hui 50 appels de
personnes qui disent vous avez vu
hanouna aurait dû le prendre sur ces
mythes alors déjà je suis pas le patron
de ses huit déjà s'appuyer pour
commencer massy et non non je vous
expliquais toute l'histoire
le oko le retour du burger quiz donc
c'est un événement très attendu alain
chabat on avait d'ailleurs fait la
promotion dans l'émission village médias
sur europe 1 et lors de son passage pour
le savoir alain chabat et moi on se
connaît assez bien parce que j'étais son
stagiaire à l'époque de comédie et voilà
donc je le puis les croisés très souvent
et il avait assuré qu'il n'était pas
venu me voir pour discuter d'un retour
du burger quiz
il explique avoir été voir canal je vous
expliquais vraiment ce qui s'est passé
et si le burger quiz a failli être sur
ces 8 ou par garde pourquoi ça ne s'est
pas fait sur ces 8 me sur le canal
horizons la propose évidemment à canal
en premier c'était ses brûlures couzinet
un canal donc c'est quand même la
moindre des choses mais ça les a pas
intéressé alors je ne sais pas
exactement pourquoi on appelle on n'a
pas été voir cyril hanouna 1 comme je le
lis à droite et à gauche on a été voir
canada cyril d'ailleurs vous voulez le
reprend il ya quelques années je crois
au tour de 2012 2013
à l'époque c'était pas du tout
d'actualité
alors c'est vrai alain chabat il ya
quelques années pour le reprendre sur
sur ces mythes ou sur canal+ alors je
vous dis la vérité
et alors alain avait pas la bonne info
parce que les producteurs jérôme revon
et stéphane gâteau sont venus me voir
ici pour me le proposer sur ses mii on
avait donc même l'intention de le mettre
à 18 heures je vous le dis sur ces 8 à
un moment peut-être en pendant les
vacances pour faire tourner entre c'est
que de la télé et le burger quiz on
avait même il m'a mêmes programmes
proposés l'animateur on ça devait être
peut-être bertrand chamerois qui aura
animé le burger quiz j'étais je vous dis
la vérité sur bertrand chamerois je leur
ai dit j'adore berthe
mais je trouve un peu vert pour
présenter un gros barnum comme ça
j'avais proposé un autre animateur
j'avais proposé je vous dis j'avais
proposé camille combal voilà pour
représenter et j'avais dit mais l'idéal
ce serait qu'un chabat revienne qu'il en
fasse quelques numéros
donc on était hyper chaud on avait même
fait les budgets puisque ya des rires
pourquoi j'ai ramené comme dans les
émissions politiques le directeur
général h2o donc la boîte de production
qui va tout vous expliquer comme celle
là plus d'ambiguïté on est juste à la
voilà donc on avait le dossier jouer oui
mais on est passé on va te dire on est
passé à côté de burger quiz voilà ça a
cartonné hier
nous on voulait le faire voilà donc on
avait le dossier avant 2017 novembre
2010 cette voie là on devait le faire
peur l'échéancier tout et voilà on avait
on avait tous et donc qu'est ce qui
s'est passé mais lionel on a tout envoyé
la chaîne s'est réunie ils ont été un
peu de temps nous on était d'accord
camille combal tulle a raconté et puis
pas de nouvelles de la part de la chaîne
ils sont allés voir tf1 ce qui est
normal qu en surproduction éléments
jouent leur jeu c'est vrai et on leur a
dit allez voir peut-être tmc tf1
peut-être que ça va les intéresser je
pense que c'est c'est bien pour eux ils
sont allés les voir et tmc à tf1 ont
pris le projet mais en tout cas on peut
vous assurer voilà qu'on nous avait
proposé burger quiz
et deuxième chose on n'était pas hyper
chaud sur ces huit jours il dit pour
reprendre deux vieilles marques alors il
ya des gens qui disent oui mais sur ses
vitres ya le grand frère illias avis de
recherche qui va revenir mais voilà on a
déjà beaucoup de nouvelles dans cette
marque qui reviennent lenval ancestral
qu'on va lancer une nouvelle marque qui
s'appelle la scoumoune
on a envie aussi de tenter de nouvelles
choses donc bravo à tmc et nt1 vrai pour
le succès mais c'est génial juste je
vous le dis un moment aussi ses huit m'a
dit oui cyril on aimerait bien que ce
soit toi qui l'animent gili les mecs je
peux pas faire de l'antenne de 11h à
minuit
donc voilà donc j'ai refusé la
présentation du burger jannie voilà on
prend vraiment et on le prenait 6 alain
chabat faisait voilà les 40 premiers
numéros parce que je pense que la vraie
force de burgers tout cela n'a pas trop
dormi
scor rien soir on va pas se mentir
demain vous mettez n'importe quel autre
animateur échéant si j'avais présenté
moi burger quiz sur ces mythes
je vous le dis on aurait fait huit cent
mille alain chabat il fait 2 millions
donc voilà c'est alain chabat il est
extrêmement populaire et je pense que
c'est le meilleur là dedans il faut que
vous sachiez quelque chose c'est que
quand même alain avait passé la main aux
autres animateurs à l'époque de canal+
ils avaient tous un divisé l'audience
par deux nations voilà alain chabat très
populaire on l'a vu et donc bravo à
thème c'est nous c'est tout ce qu'on a à
dire très court pour ce cas là voilà de
nice cannes
[Applaudissements]